[Music]
let's play aggressively
okay we have another black against
jeffrey salibu
all right well we're going to play the
queen's gambit as we always do no we're
not because we're going to face the
cauli system okay
we have not faced the kalia to my
knowledge and this also might transpose
into a reverse stone well we'll see
the best move against the kali the most
non-committal move is to play knight f6
uh just developing the knight and seeing
what white does
a lot of okay so knight c3 is already
bad we've went through this all many
many times
uh knight c3 and queen's gambit
positions in queens pawn game is almost
always a bad move positionally because
it blocks the c pawn and the c pawn
should always be on c4 in these
positions
so how does black actually explain what
is the most principled move for black in
such positions well let's think about it
logically knight c3 is partially bad
because the d4 pawn
essentially becomes a weakness if white
can't play c3
as white often does in the kali then the
pawn on d4 becomes quite vulnerable and
we exploit it by playing a kind of
reverse queen's gambit we play c5 and we
never are afraid of d take c5 in these
positions which happens but you guys
already know that dc5 is almost never
scary and here's the important thing you
don't have to rush
and i need to emphasize this like
very
strongly you don't need to rush to take
this pawn
so i a lot of you are thinking let's
play e6 and take the spot there's
nothing wrong with that but my approach
is let's develop normally and when we
have a convenient opportunity then we're
going to push the e pawn or we're going
to play queen a5 and win the pawn i
don't like the movie 5 here i don't like
the movie 5 here
and i'll explain this after the game i
don't want to spend too much time let's
just develop rp let's just develop our
knight
i'll show you why i don't like e5 after
the game e5 can can can lead to some
over extension issues
it's it's similar in the vienna gambit
this pawn isn't going anywhere it can't
be sustained it can't be defended well
so it doesn't make sense to go crazy
just to try to win it back as quickly as
possible okay so in short the reason i
don't like e5 here is because white has
the move bishop b5 that creates a pin
against the knight and it actually
threatens the e pawn and then if we push
the pawn again we create a big outpost
for right on the d4 square
so in this position there's a couple of
approaches we could take i like to move
bishop g4 developing the bishop
i also like the move e6 and i like the
move i kind of like the move a6 but i
don't want to weaken the b6 square
actually knight a4 knight b6 becomes an
idea in those positions
so there's a lot of possible approaches
here
let's play bishop g4 let's develop the
bishop outside of the pawn chain so that
when we play e6 we are not blocking the
bishop in okay
and in fact after h3 we could very
uh we we might take the knight we might
take the knight just to dispense with
the bishop entirely okay it goes bishop
e2 now we go e6
and now we have the ideal you see
because we didn't hurry with the movie
six we got an ideal position we got our
bishop outside of the pawn chain thank
you eric and blackjack and now when we
okay queen d3 is pretty meaningless move
we can take the pawn and we've got
everything in perfect order my guess is
maybe he's preparing e4 i don't know
e4 in this position without castling
just seems too risky though
okay this is not obviously this is not
scary i mean
when when you attack just with a lone
queen
that never produces the effect you want
it to produce
um what should we do well no we
shouldn't castle our bishop is hanging
our bishop we we need to defend our
bishop
but yeah bishop b6 i mean
not we can also play queen e7 by the way
defending both the bishop yeah white has
to move knight e5 but that's also not
dangerous
i'm guessing that he might play knight
e5
okay
why is it not what should we do here the
first thing we should we should not what
we should not do is panic right this
looks scary but remember that white is
attacking essentially with two pieces
and we have our entire army at our
disposal this stuff never works
first we need to take his bishop
before we do anything we need to get rid
of the g4 bishop because it is being
attacked don't forget about that don't
play rook c8 here and this is what you
want to not do when your opponent plays
a move a lot of people have this tunnel
vision where you say oh he's attacking
c6
spend a couple of seconds making sure
you're identifying all of the threats
that's how you forget about a piece
that's on the side of the board you're
not paying attention we want to take you
to
and only after he takes presumably with
a knight is it a good idea to play rook
ca
if i were playing a classical game i
would even consider sacrificing that
pawn but in the interest of playing
solid chess yeah let's play rook c8 to
defend the knight
we can also play queen c7 by the way
queezies that might have been even
better
because it would have simultaneously
attacked the knight
a6 is
possible
but unnecessary in fact i want his queen
to be on b5 knight d4
okay
okay
so this is where it's important to
not start playing reactively so there's
a couple of approaches we could play the
move queen up to d6
we could play queen up to d6 in order to
defend the knight and threaten his
knight
but we could also castle we could just
let white take on c6
and aim for the initiative afterward but
again let's play solid chess let's play
queen d6 let's not
give him any of what he wants
queen d6 i would recapture with the pawn
because that creates a mobile pawn mass
in the center and it attacks the queen
so it's a move with tempo
so far i hope uh my moves are making
sense now you might ask well why didn't
i play queen c7 queen c7 is an
alternative both moves are possible but
i somehow feel like the queen on d6 is
nicely placed between the pawns and also
another subtlety when white castle short
i will immediately have the move bishop
c7 so i'm like pre-building a battery
whereas the queen on c7 wouldn't permit
that battery to happen
okay queen a6 attacking the rook of
course moving the rook is not the best
way to defend it the best way to defend
it is to castle
the best way to defend it is of course
the castle
and now everything is developed white is
very weak positionally he's wasting a
lot of tempe and it's time to start
punishing him
now punishing
such play is not always easy
and it's not like we're winning we're
not winning yet we just need to start
grabbing more space putting our pieces
on better squares and ultimately if he
continues this kind of play stuff is
going to manifest itself so we've got
two ways
to grab more space we can play c5 or we
can play e5 both moves are great both
moves are totally fine but i like the
idea of going c5 because on the next
move we could go c4 and i don't like e5
as much because i i'm married to the
idea of playing bishop c7 after white
castle so i want to keep this diagonal
open if that makes sense i want to keep
this diagonal open
and i just like this pawn chain i don't
know i like the spawn chain
also we can put our knight on e4
shall we let's put our 94 let's
centralize
keep grabbing space keep making progress
keep pushing them off the board
no rocket science here these moves are
just natural good wholesome positional
moves
and then we can support it with the move
f5 the pillsbury knight
this is important not to overthink these
moves
um so this is a very important moment he
wants to trade the knight on e4
it's a great example of trading on our
own terms this is where f5 is a great
move
why is f5 such a great move because if
he takes any forward the knight we will
take with the f pawn well why is that
good you might ask well it's good
because first of all we have another
pawn in the center look at this these
are a lot of pawns in the center we also
have a lot of pressure down the f-file
and that pressure could be converted
into something pretty realistic bishop
d2
well let's continue
improving the position of our pieces
i have to say he's not playing badly
yeah rook f7 is a great move rook f7 is
a wonderful move because it prepares to
double rooks on the f-file
white might castle long
let's double rooks on the f-file and now
we're threatening rook takes f2
he might reactively play rook f1 and
that would blunder the h-pawn
that might happen notice that we're also
preventing him from castling queen side
because we're gonna take f2 in that case
queen g4 great move i have to say our
opponent is playing quite well despite
his initial play
we can't take the pawn because we get
checkmated
now we have to find a good way to defend
to somehow prevent that
while also not damaging our position i
think now is the time to play e5
i think now is the time to play e5 yes
and rook takes f2 is a big threat which
is completely ignored by our opponent
thank you very much
and finally we have gained material this
is where his position is very likely to
collapse quickly
there is the move queen takes e4 here i
i saw it it's not dangerous a3 wow okay
total collapsing blundering another pawn
we will take it thank you very much
okay
now we need to be careful here because
our position is under a little bit of
pressure even though it seems like
everything is over he's got this bishop
on c3 it's exerting pressure down the
diagonal there's an x-ray we can't fall
asleep here
and to this end the move d4
is let me think about it no d4 is
possible
d4 is possible but there is a very
important tactical subtlety there let's
well actually no d4 there's bishop b4
d4 there's bishop b4
and the funny thing is even that
position is probably winning
d4 there's bishop before so bishop b4 is
a threat
bishop before is the threat are there
any other threats well there's the
threat of queen takes c4 but that's a
lot less dangerous
hmm
so i know what we want to do i know what
we need to do
we should start
well no queen f6 blunders d5 let's start
by bringing this rook back to f4 this is
in order to defend against queen takes
e4
then on the next move we're gonna bring
our bishop back to c5 i know it doesn't
like glamorous but i think it defends
against everything
bishop c5 defends against bishop b4 and
it moves the bishop away from a spot
where i don't like the bishop on e3 i
really don't because it was the
undefended it was dangling there and on
c5 it's protected by the queen now we're
ready to keep pushing our center pawns
d4 e3 etc
this is
these are hard moves to play sometimes
because they're retreating moves
and and you really have to incisively
diagnose the threats in order to play
them
yeah now we're ready to play d4 and reap
the rewards of our play
unless he goes rook he one then we have
a better move
look at this bishop on c5 see where it
can go we can go to f2 potentially
h4 this is not dangerous we take a
second to
ask ourselves whether this actually
creates any threats it doesn't
and now it's time for us to
start pushing the pawns i would even
start with a movie three
i would even start with a movie three
and the reason why is after d4 bishop d2
this is a very small subtlety but if we
play d4 bishop d2 and then we play e3
could somebody tell me what we run into
what do we run into if we start with d4
and then play e3 just a small you know
tactical subtlety
we allow bishop takes c3 and we don't
want to allow it now we play d4 and
everything is under control in fact the
bishop is essentially trapped
and
there's two ways to win this game we can
keep pushing our pawns in the center or
let's not fall asleep on the b file so
even a move like bishop takes a3
blasting open his king would be
completely winning as well or we could
reposition the the afro to the b file
and just go for checkmate on the king
because white's king is completely alone
i hope you haven't forgotten about that
okay bishop b4 obviously we want to take
twice this is child's play
and now of course we we can forget about
our central upon majority because we're
on the cusp of checkmating him
yeah that game was made a lot easier so
what's the fastest path to checkmate who
can tell me in such positions you have
to know the pattern there's a mating
pattern that ends the game in two moves
and it's not rook b8 although that is
obviously completely winning it is to
play c3 and the lobster pins were made
with queen a3 when b3 is played
don't pre-move queen a3 because you
could leave his pawn on b2 but you can
pre-move queen b2 checkmate
okay no defense
yeah this is something to remember this
could be a bishop by the way
or it could be a knight and all of that
would be checkmate
basically yeah knight c3 is bad this is
the kali system white generally plays
bishop d3 and c3 here knight c3
now you might say well i've seen you
play knight c3 yes i have played knight
c3
but you don't want to combine knight c3
with the movie e3 that blocks the bishop
in this is the jabal london and i don't
recommend the java london for anybody
under 2000 because it's an
anti-positional opening and jabal london
is not a good way to practice your
basics because it requires violation of
basic positional rules
okay
that's like i don't know learning how to
cook and going straight into making
you know
gordon ramsay's specialty dish like you
want to start by making spaghetti and
meatballs
and the basics before you move on to
fricking
beef stroganoff with thousand dollar
truffles
okay um e3 knight f6 knight c3
c5 c5 is sort of the move to punish
these kinds of things
dc5
okay so
why not e5 so again e5 in this position
i don't like particularly because of
knight f3
and if we play knight c6 we allow bishop
e5 and i just i don't like this scenario
because this is hanging
why is this hanging well because of the
pin
and if we push it then we give up all
these dark squares we allow knight t4 of
course it's a big positional concession
and if we if we play around here if we
play bishop d7 you know what could end
up happening what could end up happening
is that white
takes on c6 and then plays b4
and okay fortunately we have the move a5
here but if white's bishop were to be
developed then why would be able to play
a3
so
it's not always necessary to grab
control of the center like this knight
c6 knight f3 we decided on bishop g4
okay i'll get ask your questions when i
get to that point in the game this
should be two
okay so we play e6 again e5 is possible
but it also weakens the d5 square i i
quite like this pawn arrangement instead
okay queen d3 is very strange i mean
white should probably just castle here
and accept a worse position queen d3
bishop c5 queen b5
okay bishop b6 knight e5
first we take the bishop
um
now we play rook c8
okay knight d4
and yeah in in in in a classical game in
a game that i was i was playing i would
have castle in reality this is not a
pawn sacrifice this is not actually upon
sack
you might ask why not takes takes takes
how does black win the pawn back with
interest
how does black win the pawn back with
interest not on the next move but in two
moves
no epidemic because the bishop was on e2
attacking the queen so queen d7 no it
does not win a piece no no no no it
doesn't win a piece because of knight d4
and if you take on d4 there's queen
takes d7 now in this situation bishop c3
would be great but unfortunately there's
a pawn on v2
so this is a situation that's very
precarious for white but instead it's a
better idea just to take and take and
clearly black is much better because we
have the second rank the other rook is
coming to see a bishop a5 check is an
idea this is terrible for white
or or we could play queen d6
and follow up knight d4 with a move like
e5
and ultimately we could take c2 so
either way white black is much better
but here i wanted to play it in a more
straightforward fashion yeah we can play
bishop c3 to ruin a structure but it's
not the best the plaque can do
queen a6 castles
queen c7 as i said is an alternative it
really doesn't matter the main thing is
that i wanted to be able to build the
battery against the king
okay so we castle
again e5 c5 are all possible you could
play knight d4 here as well there's many
alternatives in a position like this
but we're just improving our pieces move
by move knight e4 centralizing and then
supporting the knight with a pawn
um does knight b5 work instead of knight
f3
well what do you mean by work
well what happens after night before
just move our queen back for instance
and now the knight is vulnerable we're
threatening to go c4 and slice off the
queen from the knight
again i always say this don't be afraid
of moves that attack your queen
particularly a message to people below
1300 do not
inherently moves that threaten your
queen are not inherently scary they
could be scary if they do something else
they're scary if it's a fork
but just because it attacks your queen
doesn't mean the move is good you move
your queen back
and then you're threatening to win the
knight with c4
didn't f5 weaken the dark squares well
first of all you can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs
when you're afraid of making a move
because the quote-unquote weakens
squares
what you want to ask yourself is first
of all i mean is it worth doing it
sometimes it's worth weakening a square
sometimes the move is so good you're
accomplishing so much that it's worth
weakening but the main thing is can
white really exploit the weakness of the
e5 do you really see white putting a
knight there
i mean because i don't look at how
passive white is how is white even
possibly going to put a knight on e5 and
even if he does that's not going to be
significant so very often it's worth
weakening a square
when you believe that your opponent is
very unlikely to access it or even if he
accesses it's not dangerous and the
example that i always show
to to hammer this concept in and i've
shown this before on stream this is one
of my favorite positional examples of
all time it's nothing like insane but
it's it's a very crystal clear
illustration of this concept i call this
inaccessibility
you can weaken a square when it's
inaccessible to your opponent
even if the weakness seems extreme
here's the game so this is a game as you
can see between two very strong gm
sergician and tomaszewski white is
armenian
gm black is russian gm
uh from 2013
european team championship
okay so this very uh
mundane looking position occurred on the
board after black's 26th move what can
you tell me about this what can we
say about this position well we can say
a few things
those of you with any experience in this
structure
should spot this thing that's going on
on the queenside which of course is a
queen side attack
white is attacking black's queen side
with his pawns
why does a monopoly on the dark source
because you've got a dashboard bishop
and so what move comes to mind here for
one what is the obvious move that white
seems to want to play him i'm even
indicating with an arrow
well that move is b5 right well what
happens if white plays b5 well if i
plays b5 black will take on b5 and the
reason sargeant didn't play it yet is
because he was afraid that black would
generate counterplay
what move was he afraid of in this
position how can black get counter play
and really mix things up
make it difficult for white to focus his
attention and on the king on the queen
said yeah black can play e5
why is he five dangerous because if you
take on e5 and the knight takes e5 you
can see where the knight is going the
knight is going to c4 and white has a
very serious weakness on e3 that's going
to get attacked
by the rook and by the knight and the
knight gets free
so what did sargentine do in this
position
and this is a move which looks
profoundly anti-positional it looks
terrible and yet it's a brilliant
positional move white actually ended up
playing f4 let me control z a bunch of
times just to get the notation back
white plays the move f4
now this looks terrible for two reasons
it blocks the bishop and but more
importantly look at this massive square
on e4 that it weakens if black ever gets
a knight on e4 white's going to be
positionally busted and yet
can black actually get the knight on e4
the answer to that question is crazy it
will take eight moves for black to
actually get a knight on e4 because he
can't go to d6 he can't go to g5 what
black has to do to get the 994 is knight
h8
knight
two
three
then you have to move the king four
five
six
seven
eight
so it's eight moves until white like
actually gets the knight to e4
and obviously that is plenty of time for
white to attack the queen side
so
yeah so white plays f4
and as for the bishop well that's a lot
less important than preventing e5 the
bishop will find a home
eventually the bishop ends up finding a
home
so here we go sargassian
sargassian breaks through on the
queenside and the game lasted for a long
time
but ultimately white white get gained
this attack white attacked on both sides
and the bishop ultimately
got itself a nice little parking spot on
h4
so
it's okay to weaken certain squares
when you believe that
something calls for something's more
important than that
so i hope that answers the question take
stakes now we have the crystal clear
idea of attacking f2 this pawn is
cramped by the e4 pawn
and so therefore we double rooks on the
f-file
now what would happen if white had
castled queenside
well if why that captain castled
queenside we could complete the doubling
of the rooks but after orchestra f1 we
would have to switch gears
what does that mean well let's think
about the drawback of castling queenside
is there any file that we could use
in order to attack
yeah we can play e5 oh yeah queen takes
h2 sorry i forgot about that queen takes
h2 wins the pawn but let's say he plays
rook df1
we could use the b file so one thing we
could do here is actually just go rook
b8 and then rook fb7 we could re-double
our rooks on another file that's a
completely viable strategy
you doubled on one file then something
more important came along and you
doubled on another file
and if white plays bishop c3 in order to
support the b2 pawn well we already have
a method of kicking this bishop away
from c3 we could go e5 and then on the
next move we could go d4 and the attack
really here is overwhelming
so flexibility of thinking is important
once
okay e5 this is already very bad the the
reason this is very bad is because if
white plays rook f1 we have bishop takes
e3
okay probably white should castle
kingside
that this probably is the the lesser
evil but even here we go deforming just
look at this this looks amazing
so rook takes f2 now the game is over we
just take all of his pawns and this rook
at forma was important
because again if we play d4 we blunder
bishop b4
if we play
rookie 8 for example we give up queen
takes you this is a big deal this move
is really nasty
um and if we take the queen our entire
pawn structure is ruined
so the way that i approached this is i
said well
let's defend against one of these
threats with tempo
and then let's drop the bishop back to
c5 in order to take the sting out of
bishop b4 that's why i played rook f4
yeah we could have alternatively played
the move sorry the reason i didn't unpin
is because e5 would hang it's not that
easy to unpin without giving without not
giving up the e5 or d5 pawns in fact
it's impossible
yeah we might sean pin so that's
something to be investigated
so this is just a very careful sequence
and then we start pushing up on z3 t4
and the rest is easy we take them c3
yeah
so basically i bishop f2 is also good
obviously bishop f2 is perfectly fine as
well
um
in fact we oh we can win the queen we
can win the queen bishop f2
if queen h3 then rook h4 traps the queen
and if queen g5 rook 8 of 5 also traps
the queen that's crazy i i saw the rook
h4 queen trap i didn't see this move
so yeah we could have won the queen
actually very very very very pretty
can you explain the e3 pawn pushing
instead of d4 sure
so the reason i pushed e3 instead of d4
is because after d4 bishop d2
e3 is not possible anymore because of
bishop takes e3 and you can't take the
bishop because your queen is pinned so i
i really wanted this pawn on e3 first
yeah
okay the rest is the lobster pincer mate
and that's that's game over
some dumb driver says well technically
no but
technically white would have bishop
before yeah i agree you're right
no but it is still ah in queen d7 you
have queen e7 damn
good catch man
yeah that's a great catch i guess here
we would have to trade
we would have to trade
that was nice yeah yeah very well very
well indicated and of course this is
still residable for white but
uh but yeah bishop before saves the
queen
nope queen takes b4 is bad
not bad isn't losing but queen queen
before there's the counter desperado
queen takes f5
what's up ak senia good to see you
it takes before now again still this is
completely winning because we go d4 and
e3 but
it's not worth giving up the exchange
any more questions about this game
[Music]
you